[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king in the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and my daughter
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it starting off this
hour is going to be susan in
jacksonville florida hi susan how are
you
great how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world
well
i just started listening about two
months ago and
i've really started to try make some
changes and my baby steps have been all
over the place
and
my investments are
heavily weighted into two spots which i
know is not
the way i'm supposed to be doing it so
i'm turning 60 this year and i'm like
holy cow
i'm probably not where i should be
and i need to figure out how to get
where i should be
that's a good question susan so where
are the two you said the two main
investments where are they at where's
your money at in them
well
i have a lot of equity in my home
because it is getting close to being
paid off good um
yeah and of course like i said that's a
baby step out of order
i'll tell you more but and i have
heavily i have stock in my company
and it's privately held
stock
but
owning a good amount of a minimal amount
of in my company pays me a good bonus
every month
um so
it's it's great my stock has more than
doubled in the three years i've owned
company stock
it's worth right now about 519 000.
what's your home worth
um it's probably worth
uh 600 or a little better look at you
millionaire 60 year old well done
all right yeah and um the uh what other
investments have you got 401k
i do
um
it's only got in it now with the way the
market is right now it's around 160.
good good okay what else
um
my total retirement with some old
iras that i had that have just been
sitting for years
my total total retirement including that
160 is about 257
um
i have
i do have a 30 000
emergency fund what do you make of your
and i
well i i make a good living i make a
little better than 400. good for you
what do you do
i'm a dentist awesome oh now i get the
stock okay cool can you cash out of the
uh some of
the company stock
is it set up where you can get out of it
at some point they will have
when they have you know they only offer
that at certain times so
um
there's none coming up right now but i
think there will come a time
maybe in the next year or so that i
might be able to yeah okay
so here here's the thing um number one
she's done a great job i was adding up
all your numbers susan i was like
there's nothing in here
there's nothing in here that just like
got a stupid arrow over the top of it i
mean you've done a great job
you know but you've identified the the
danger zone
is if some bizarre thing happened and
this one company went broke
you would lose one third of your net
worth
yes and that's that's that scared you
when you kind of looked at it that way
and thought now that that's not the end
of the world but that's why i don't want
too much in single stock like i talked
to a lady years ago uh i've used this
example on there many times procter and
gamble she'd been with them 38 years and
she had 750 000
procter and gamble stock only when she
got ready to retire it went down to 250
000
in value
and so because she had it all in one
company she had you know that lack of
spread around that lack of
diversification made her vulnerable and
that's the only thing that scares me
here i don't think there's anything to
panic about but if you could get out of
like half of this
and still keep your bonuses when the
next time comes around i would just
because of safety
yes
and that would be my plan if i keep 250
000 i do keep that bonus which
pays me for like 3 500 a month yeah well
then do it yeah that's a great return
and it's worth it it's worth some risk
you know but um you know yeah i'd get
out of that what are you on the house
again
i owe probably about 110. okay so pay
that off this year
yes i do have one other thing you're
going to probably like fall off your
chair because i told you i'm turning 60.
um i still owe 45 000 in student loans
okay
that would be you you would be like a
normal dentist
warning to you young dentists okay here
you're talking to a 60 year old still
got her student loan debt so i know but
i was i was 39 when i got out of dental
school so i was old when i got out okay
so here's the deal
what do you want to enter into when
you're 70 i think if i were you i would
want to enter into zero debt including
my house
and not so much tied up in the dental
practice
right and that's it do you have a plan
for retirement susan like do you have an
age you're shooting for
yeah you know i
right now i want to just cut back to
three days a week soon maybe go to two
days a week by like
65.
okay
i don't know what i would do with myself
if i wasn't because i was gonna say but
you can do i mean you men you threw out
70 i don't know why specifically i'm
just saying 10 years from now you know
but in five years you could have oh you
need to be there sooner than that yeah
you need to you need to get the house
paid off and get the student loan paid
off as soon as possible
i plan to do that because i have a condo
that i'm is up for sale right now and it
has a lot of equity in it okay then
that'll knock everything out and then
let's get out let's get out of the let's
have a plan to not be in
this stock at all when you hit final
retirement but not be in it as heavy
within a couple of years if you can move
out of it does that make sense okay yes
that's
that makes absolute sense and so then
you're sitting on you know you'll be
sitting on a million dollars in mutual
funds at that point and you're going to
be sitting on a million dollars worth or
close to million dollars worth of real
estate in four or five years
and um and and you've got this fabulous
income so yeah you've just done a great
job kiddo well done
oh thank you i just didn't feel like
i've been doing a very good job at all
well it all you needed was i i think all
you need is some of the rough edges
polished off
yeah so the two debt things are sloppy
and the heavy weight on the stock is
scary
yes
that's all
yeah
okay good job thank you thanks for
calling honored to have yourself funny
how much is just perspective because
when you're sitting in it and her she's
like i'm overwhelmed i have all these
things and i feel like oh gosh i still
have them no no and you look at the big
picture when you're out of it to be like
well no here's the puzzle pieces and
it's pretty simple
so the perspective of money it's that's
what's helpful to always have someone
else in your life to kind of smell i
mean
i mean i'm intimidated about my teeth
and she's intimidated by her money so
that's that's kind of normal you know
when's the last time you've been to a
susan a dennis dave
just the other day this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
oh
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author ramsey personality my daughter is
my co-host today at open phones triple
eight eight two five five
two two five every time you hear someone
do their debt-free scream on the show
it's because at some point they said
enough i'm not living like this anymore
i've had it
when you get mad like that
that's what they did your life will
change
right now inflation
stupid credit cards gas prices killing
you
student loans been around so long you
think it's a pet
and you start to believe you're not in
control of your money well you are
you're wrong you have control of your
money there's a lot you can do there's
some things some things you can't
control but you can control the
controllables in any situation and we
can show you how
you can change your future financial
peace university
the proven step-by-step plan nearly 10
million people have been through this
course learning how to get out of debt
become masters at budgeting building
wealth and outrageously generous and you
can learn every bit of that and we can
show you how to become baby steps
millionaires
stop letting debt money stress freak out
i don't know how to do math whatever
your excuses finally you got to stop and
go enough
enough i'm tired i work too hard i make
too much money to be this broke
ramsay solutions dot com slash enough
and you can start financial peace
university right now ramsey solutions
dot com slash enough we will show you
how to fix this
all right let's uh look at blinds.com
they're our question of the day find out
for yourself why they're the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal and today's question
comes from jimmy in kentucky my wife and
i are on baby step three and would love
to buy a home but we're nowhere near
able to put down money on a house we are
concerned that the market will continue
to increase
before we can get a down payment saved
up can we use my va loan to take
advantage of the zero percent payment
down payment
to get into a house sooner and refinance
in three to five years
jimmy
i'm gonna say
no i mean va loans they're just it's
just not it's not a great option i mean
there's so much with the fees everything
that that that is in that
uh it makes it a difficult it's a
difficult mortgage and
between fha va and conventional it's the
most expensive
unless you are disabled if you're a
fully disabled veteran then they waive a
lot of the fees and stuff but it's not
it's not a good deal for you and
basically what you're doing is you're
trying to find a way to game the system
you know you want to scan the system and
the system isn't broken it means delayed
pleasure and yes house prices are going
to continue to go up they're not going
to continue to go up like they have been
the market has slowed down substantially
uh we anticipate real estate prices in
the year
2022 to go up about 7
next year 23 which is when you would be
buying a house or 24 they're going to go
up four to five percent a year that is
not going to price you out of the market
jimmy what will price you out of the
market is doing it dumb
and moving into something when you're
broke and you have no down payment and
you're not ready to buy you're going to
get in a problem you're you know they
they're
you know you're going to create friction
here in your life it's not gonna be fun
and you're gonna turn we want you to
have a house we don't want the house to
have you yeah and that's what ends up
happening so much we talked about it on
the show yesterday with george that
you know your home it's such an
emotional thing right it's like where
your family is it's where you sleep at
night it's where you do your meals i
mean like it is it's such an emotional
part of your life
and so many people rush into that so
it's an emotional part of your life and
it's the most expensive part of your
life it's usually the largest purchase
you ever make
and so because of that it's like people
make not wise decisions when it comes to
their money with their houses because
they just let their emotions get ahead
of them whether it's fear whether it's
longing for somebody there's all these
stupid people that are around you
telling you all the time to buy
something you got to buy out you got to
buy house you got a house you got a
house you can be a renter you got to buy
a house everybody oh god oh god oh god
you're going to get priced out okay okay
and you know what is your beautician an
economist
the lady doing your nails is not an
economist oh my god you know so stop
listening to these broke people
with their craziness uh because i've
heard that for 30 years yeah for 30
years i've heard i'm going to get priced
out of the market and i can tell you
real estate is considerably more
expensive than when i started this show
30 years ago
but but you know and it'll be more
expensive 30 years from now when you're
still doing the show so but the uh uh
god will in the creek don't rise but you
know oh my gosh
the uh uh that that's but there's a lot
of outside pressure family members and
everybody else oh you had my house yet
but you've been married 26 seconds and
you hadn't bought a house oh my god and
there's all this craziness out there
well that and then on top of all the
emotion of just the recent yeah
real estate i mean all of it right so
it's it's it's
i don't know there's a lot 2020 was one
of the highest increases in house prices
in history yeah of all time i mean in
modern history
and 29
it went up oh my that's unbelievable
unprecedented as they say in the covid
language but yeah oh my gosh yeah that's
just crazy and so uh it scares the crud
out of you but it's not it's not that's
not going to be
what happens going forward it's also not
going to crash for those of you waiting
on the prices to go down well let me
let's talk about this because i've been
there's there's been so much i feel like
even in the recent probably like week or
two about the real estate market because
there's i read an article this morning
the seven cities where it continues to
increase substantially right so there
was so i read that and then there are
places though that they're seeing you're
seeing prices go down go down
and so
the important thing there is to remember
that that's still buyers i'm sorry
sellers
some of them are still in the mindset of
oh i can make yeah so much they're still
looking for a sucker coming from another
city so when you're seeing those prices
i just want to know your thoughts on it
is it going back to just true home value
of what the what the house is really
worth
versus the inflated prices and so when
when do you know what your house is
valued at like a true value after all
the craziness of it going up so fast
is it that you can can you still run
copies like you know what i mean because
going up so fast is a reality okay so
the definition of
market value for real estate yep when i
was in appraisal class yep a thousand
years ago is still in college is still
the definition and every real estate
test you ever take to get your real
estate license is when a willing buyer
meets a willing seller
and neither are under duress
okay
webster i'm gonna call you well i mean
so here's the deal so you have a buyer
and a seller and neither one of them are
freaking out okay okay the seller is not
motivated by a divorce or a bankruptcy
or something else okay okay the buyer is
not over motivated because the last
three houses they put offers in they
didn't get and so the marketplace is so
white hot that the buyer is under duress
and so some of these buyers were paying
above market value but their purchase
does not enter into an appraisal
that that property is not an actual
indicator of value okay because the one
of the parties was under duress yes you
can't use okay a foreclosure on your
street does not affect the value of your
house because one of the parties was
under duress okay so that's not a value
how are you so how people out there that
are wanting
to buy yourself like how do you run
comps now because i'm like usually you
just run comms
you run comps and if one of them sticks
up and shows all are going to stick up
right
maybe maybe i mean if you if everybody
was a white hot buyer in the whole area
then the value probably has gone up yeah
because the marketplace was in the rest
right
but if you've got some one-offs like you
know we we talked about during the thing
i live in a neighborhood where like
like almost all the houses are sold in
it's a nice neighborhood uh sold
recently where california people moving
in with california equity
and the tennessee people are sitting
there going
i got a sucker on the hook here yeah
they're gonna way overpay because they
can't get a house there's a shortage and
so they're gonna they're overpaying
substantially yeah over value and and so
enough of that happens then other people
get greedy and they're like well i
didn't really want to sell my house but
if i could sell it for that i'd sell it
yeah what the heck and yeah and one of
the guys i was playing golf with we
talked about that during the streaming
thing that we're doing he goes i put
mine on the market and put an extra 200
000 bucks on it looking for one of those
california sucker fish i'm gonna hook me
one you know and it didn't sell
yeah and he said i haven't been able to
hook one so the market has calmed down
the market has calmed down and the
migration from california or new york or
wherever into these other uh markets
you know yeah the southeastern markets
primarily is slowed down yep but we've
had a million plus people displaced from
just california and new york yep just
those two states moved out
into other markets and that
it adversely affected what is a real
value yes real value should be based on
a calm reasonable wise transaction by
both parties yes and even that goes up
three to five percent a year yep yep
it's good
so
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage ryan
and ashley are with us hey guys how are
you how's it going dave we're hot and
sweaty how are you
where do you guys live
uh we're from san diego california oh
yeah you're not used to this humidity
not at all yeah you can cut tennessee
humidity with a knife in august so uh
welcome we're glad to have you guys
thank you so all the way to nashville
from the land of california to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off um as of this monday we paid off 476
730 and 53 cents
thank you how long did this take four
and a half years all right and what was
your range of income during that time um
we started at around 250 and then after
a couple salary increases and two recent
promotions we're now at 345 000. wow
great income what do y'all do for a
living we're both in federal law
enforcement oh wow yeah okay excellent
amazing thank you for that way up there
yeah yeah thank you thank you for
federal for doing that that's amazing so
477
san diego was that the house it was that
there's the house
[Applause]
wow
you're weirdos we are yeah way to go
weirdos i love it
congratulations man you're young too how
old are you two um so our birthdays are
actually tomorrow but i'm still 40. and
i'm 38. okay all right
excellent guys well done very well done
all right tell us about this journey
what happened how'd you get connected to
the ramsey way yeah so about six years
ago my mom bought me the book retire
inspired
at that point in my career i thought
you know i read the first chapter and i
just thought i'm too young for this it
doesn't apply to me so i put the book in
a linen closet for maybe two years
before it was donated to the goodwill
um
yes fast forward to four and a half
years ago
our twin boys were just babies ryan and
i started thinking about okay what's the
earliest time we can retire and how can
we have the type of retirement that we
want
so he started doing some research and
came across the same book
um he ordered retire inspired which
connected us to you guys um we sold you
two
yeah
so we both started listening to you and
we were hooked it was hustle and grind
after that we got second jobs we sold a
paid for truck we sold anything and
everything in the house that we didn't
need anymore recycled cans rolled our
coins we were you know we would go to
the bank sometimes to make
7.50
principal payments and we would go
multiple times per week any and every
extra dollar we had went toward
principal reduction wow yeah
way to go yeah y'all are focused
intense so when you started how long did
your math tell you it was going to take
um
i think
next year yeah or december of this year
may have been the soonest we ever
thought we could do it but just as we
kept the momentum going like we would
have daily discussions how can we be
more intense what else can we do you
know just coming up with ideas all the
time we would talk every day about it
that sounds more like you turned it into
a game
yeah i mean we're just very typical game
of sacrifice yeah
but we were willing to do that you know
just to be done with it so we can move
on and um do all the things we want to
do next so i mean to have a paid for
house in california specifically san
diego i mean like
that's unbelievable you guys yeah we
like to say the math works in california
as well
so how much is it how much is this house
worth uh currently it's approximately
1.1 million
[Laughter]
so that alone before we get to your
retirement makes you a babysitter
millionaire yes sir
i'm 40 years old you did it i love it i
love it congratulations you guys thanks
how does it feel to be completely
free i mean i mean for me it hasn't set
in yet because it was literally four
days ago that we paid off the house it
was our final payment we got pictures at
chase bank and you know um it hasn't set
him yet so because we haven't had a
paycheck yet since yeah yeah right um
but i think once this first paycheck
drops next week or it's it's going to be
the grass is going to be greener for
sure can't wait what were those people
at chase bank doing you're taking
pictures
well they they knew us by name because
like
you're in there
like i said we were there multiple times
per week so we had like our favorite
tellers and all that stuff we would go
to
um the kids would come along every every
time we made a principal payment get
lollipops all that jazz so
so yeah i mean i think you know of
course they were encouraging and said
congratulations and all that but i don't
think it was a surprise
well and i think they think here's the
weird people exactly
that's what i figured you would get oh
my gosh because you are weird that's
awesome yes it's such a good way
normal's broke and you're not no we
aren't wow okay so it did take a ton of
sacrifice and there's a lot of people
listening right now that have little
kids that see yours right here in the
lobby
and they're like oh it's not worth it
like you know we just want to enjoy life
and we'll be it's our house right like
oh it's fine 30 years we'll it it'll
happen
so what do what do you say to encourage
people that even with even with a young
family
that the sacrifice i'm sure i know is
difficult yeah yeah
i can tell you for for me with the
little boys like at least not going out
to dinner was easy because when we did
try to go out to dinner it was brutal
it was brutal
thinking that's gonna change
we'd have to shove our food in you know
in 20 minutes we couldn't enjoy our 80
dinner or whatever we just flat out
stopped going to dinner and our if we
did go out to dinner it would be in and
out burger you know something real easy
yeah right
well and the kids came along this
journey with us they were out there
recycling cans with us you know anytime
they would pick up extra coins or
whatever they'd be like this for debt
free
so they were totally on board and they
supported us as well like they were you
know part of this process too so i just
think you know
sacrificing now so you can win
for the long term is totally where it's
at and we
you know the why for us
um was bigger than you know not being
able to go out to dinner or whatever for
this four and a half years it was worth
doing yeah temporary pain long-term gain
yeah live like no one else for sure
later you can live and give like numbers
yes sir wow very cool amazing job you
guys thank you well done well we're
proud of you guys what do you uh what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt here um i we think the key is
also the hardest part you know
self-discipline self-control
perseverance and contentment
not only did we learn that those were
things you know needed for financial
success they're also foundational for
being just a better person and winning
at life you know we want to set our kids
up to to win
there are not going to be any
participation trophies in our house
you know we're going to set them up for
success in any way that we can so well
in law enforcement you run into people
that have none of those things on that
list correct
no self-control no discipline no
perseverance no long-term thinking
correct and all of that results in you
being involved in their lives yes
unfortunately yes
yeah oh my goodness wow wow wow so 350
000 income not a payment
in the world
a million dollar plus house paid for
right what's the first big thing you all
want to do
oh man um we we really want to try
flying somewhere first class
yeah we like to travel first class take
our kids on awesome adventures
but we also want to give big um we have
our twin boys who um we had to do ivf to
get pregnant with them um so you know
that process is um
stressful enough so we'd like to take at
least the financial stress away from
someone else and
to pay for someone else to have ivf it's
amazing awesome well bring the kiddos up
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you you are one and
also a one-year membership to financial
peace university you can give that away
or go through it uh also a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away and
help someone so what are the names and
ages of the kiddos so this is our sweet
girl haley she's eight these are twin
boys jamison and jax and they are five i
love it good looking family thank you
you guys are great we're so proud of you
guys heroes well done all right ryan and
ashley haley jameson and jack san diego
paid for 1.2 million dollar house
everything 479 paid off man count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
three two one we're done
hayley wins
way yo hayley oh my god
[Applause]
[Laughter]
ah life is good this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my co-host today
open phones at
five two two five holly's in lexington
kentucky hey holly welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dana rachel thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
um so
my husband and i just got married about
a month ago
and we have a total 140 000 in student
loan debt
we created this plan that we're really
excited about
um it is kind of drastic though and my
mom is just really worried that we
aren't spending we're working too much
and we're not spending enough time to
really cherish their first year marriage
um
so yeah i don't know i just
it kind of made us second-guess our plan
and feel like we'll regret it one day
working too much our first year so so
what's the plan holly what
what are the hours
how fast will you pay this off kind of
like give me the give me the rundown
yeah so i'm a nurse and i just quit my
regular nursing job and switched to a
local travel nursing job and it
quadrupled my pay so i'm making about 10
000 a month after taxes with that and
then i'm also in nurse practitioning
school
and so that's i'm in clinical like two
days a week eight hours a day and then
i'm also teaching so that my school's
free
um so i'll be working around like 78
hours a week
and um
my husband's a physical therapist and he
brings in about um
four thousand a month after taxes um and
our plan is to pay off ten thousand a
month so she mom's just really scared
that we aren't
we're taking on too much too thin
i was wondering what you all thought
what do you think holly
i feel like we i feel fine really um
i don't know i just
and i've talked to some of my friends
and they think we're taking on too much
too soon
um
but like i feel like with nursing right
now like i want to
like this money may not be around next
year so i really want to take advantage
of it now
um
yeah so how old are you
26 20 okay okay and i feel like we get
this paid off in like
a year
it may be like a year and a couple
months and is your husband
is he on board would you say you guys
together you said you're both you're
both like excited about this plan you
both know what's going to take
and you both feel great about it
yeah holly i mean i think you're fine
okay you're fine yeah and i think the
emotional tie to your mom i yeah and her
approval
um
is big in your life and it would be for
right for most for most adult children
who have a good relationship with their
parents they want their parents to
approve and be happy and proud of what
they're doing so i understand a little
bit of the hesitation but
um
but let me tell you
marriage
is more stressful when you're living
paycheck to paycheck and deeply in debt
it's less stressful when you sacrifice
for a short period of time
and the financial part of your marriage
is just cleaned up the debt and you guys
have learned to work on the same be on
the same page work together as a team do
the impossible together
it's gonna i i think it actually
strengthens your marriage if you guys
are intentional about the time when
you're together then that's important
obviously um okay let's let's pretend
something okay
let's say you get five months into this
and it is having a negative effect on
you yeah
quit
yeah that's true i could just do that
yeah you're not signing up with the
military
it's a job
right
nobody said you don't that you have to
keep doing it and so if you start
melting down
in your relationship or in your mental
health or you're not taking good care of
yourself physically you're not getting
enough sleep or something silly like
that
quit
right and do and do 3 three twelves
and do your school
that would be half of what you're
talking about roughly
great and how many hours is your husband
planning to work
uh four uh he does like the traditional
40 like okay and he's got the ability to
pick up with pt too
yeah
yeah he does yeah uh you're not going to
be there he might as well be working the
emergency room
it's good money
yeah you guys have to both have the
ability to have great side hustles
right okay now again
if it reaches the point that you guys
are feeling the strain but this idea
that somehow there's
uh that you're gonna have a weaker
marriage because you work together
towards a goal with great intensity no
it'd be quite the opposite you'll have a
stronger marriage
yeah
that's true yeah it's uh i mean think
about families in the military where one
of them is deployed four months after
they're married
there's all kinds of people out there
that that prosper relationally in
kind of extreme circumstances now again
i don't want you to i'll be on your
mom's team your friend's team and that i
i wouldn't tell you to do something that
permanently damages your relationship
okay
but um some of our richest times are
when we were
scratching and clawing hustling grinding
pushing through and then we ring the
bell together
it's kind of fun
you know great but yeah we just paid off
we just paid off our first loan last
week's my last paycheck yeah it feels
really good
yeah
point at the point you think you're
gonna pass out or something you know
quit yeah just quit and holly if this
was gonna be like a five-year thing
i'd be like okay let's just like look
how to pace ourselves like you know
let's but if you're talking 12 months
and you're like man it's a sprint yeah
yeah yeah
and
i think the benefits are and again i
don't think that it has to by definition
destroy your first year of marriage
that's silly
okay yeah um but it it
on quite the contrary it could set the
tone for
we can lock arms and battle anything
together
because this is what we did this was our
first order of business out of the gate
as soon as we're married is is attack
something together
there there's a real benefit to that and
knitting you together for future
mountains that you have to climb uh and
you will have to climb future mountains
you can count on it
so uh you know that that's uh but but
but the good news is you can try this
and if it starts having an adverse
effect if your mom's fears come true
then you you know you just shut her down
and take go go pick up a standard
nursing job 372s right or 72 3 3 3 12
36 i'm sorry 36 hours yeah so um
those are everywhere there's a nursing
shortage
so um
and you know at the end of the day i it
sounds like your mom
and you have a good relationship and
she's voicing this gently if she begins
to violate a boundary at you've gotta
just remember you're now married she
doesn't ultimately have a vote
only you and your husband have a vote
right and your friends don't have a vote
and so uh and holly too you're gonna
look weird yeah
that's part of our i mean a little bit
of this plan and you know we were
talking we just had a debt-free scream
of a family with three little kids for
four and a half years picked up
coins on the side of the road they would
find and roll them and take them to the
bank i mean like it's kind of extreme
stuff because
the truth is yeah it is extreme if you
want to get out of 140 000 of student
loan debt and do it in an intense period
of time for a short period of time and
attack it
it's going to look weird to the average
26 28 year old who's like no i'm going
to keep my student loans around and just
i'm going out to eat every night
holly you got to enjoy your life holly
you're you're just doing too much
i feel that's so much of our generation
so there is a level of sacrifice that
that our that the culture is not
comfortable with because it's not normal
so again if it starts to wear down yes i
totally echo what dave said right if it
starts to damage you personally in your
marriage all of that yeah yeah i mean
that stuff is way more important to to
hold true
uh than than getting out of debt
necessarily so
there's a there's a balance there but
also you're going people are gonna make
fun of you they're gonna look at you
like you have a third eye and they're
like oh she's a little man holly
oh he's a little intense so they may say
that about you holly
but it's not always a bad thing
[Laughter]
normal's broke
be weird you know that's like our tried
and true just like well i mean
you know embrace this life
there's stuff to be had i mean what are
you if you work 40 hours a week and you
know you're gonna sit and watching
netflix i mean this is i mean really
i don't
you know i'm not saying there's anything
wrong with working 40 hours a week but
it's not like mandatory for happiness
that's that's ridiculous
so are mandatory to have good
relationships and so on
so it's good it's a good it's a good
discussion
the good news is you don't have to
choose
bad relationships and get out of debt
no you don't have to do that if you
start having a bad relationship just
cut her back that puts us out with the
ramsey show in the box
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones triple
eight eight two five
five two two five maria is in des moines
iowa hi maria welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and rachel so excited to talk to
you guys today talk good to talk to you
how can we help
um i have a question on behalf of my mom
and grandparents today but i just want
to start off and just thank you for your
program
because of it we eliminated all of our
debt cash flowed my husband's school
we're ready for baby step 456 and we
would literally be in hundreds of
thousands of dollars of debt if it
wasn't for you so i just wanted to say
thank you first and foremost well you
did it hero i'm proud of you
that's amazing maria that's amazing
thank you
um my question though isn't as fun of a
story but
um so my questions for my mom and my
grandparents um
over the last year my grandparents
moved to downsize and eliminate debt
um and eliminate their mortgage they did
that due to financial reasons and also
due to health reasons with my grandpa
but in the last about four months my
grandma was diagnosed with terminal
cancer and um she didn't do so well with
chemo so now she's on hospice care at
home i'm sorry
yeah um so i mean anyway due to being
sick she was still working up to that
point but now she obviously isn't able
to so my mom has stepped in and has
really been helping take care of them
and she's also working my grandma's
business she was a self-employed
independent contractor so she's been
working that business to help them pay
their bills but unfortunately doing that
is actually taking a toll on my mom's
financial situation as well
but since she's been more involved some
information has come to light
we found out that
my grandma might have a spending problem
and she
after the move she took out 50 more
credit cards and maxed them all out oh
my gosh
and
it gets
worse unfortunately and we learned it's
come to light that she's never paid her
taxes
um i'm being told never
ever
i've i've been told she paid some state
because she was forced to but that she
hasn't paid federal taxes
so
um my concern is the plan was once my
grandma passes which is inevitable but
that my mom is going to move in with my
grandpa and take care of him and
continue to work my grandma's business
but there's just some concerns on if
there's any risks with doing that due to
that tax issue then also
what risks do my grant will my grandpa
have or my grandma currently
due to unpaid
taxes and they're like in their mid 70s
so i mean it's been at least 30 years
i'm so sorry what a mess yeah yeah it's
really scary okay the um scary answer is
is that not paying federal income taxes
is a criminal offense
if you google how many people went to
jail last year
for not paying federal income taxes
you'll always find
a number between 2500 and 5 000 every
year that they put people in jail for
this it's a criminal offense
it's not optional
it's not like i just get to decide this
okay
now are they going to put a 70 year old
cancer patient in hospice in jail no
no they couldn't get her they couldn't
be efficient enough to get around to it
by then
okay
but it is this going to come to roost on
her estate
oh very probably
but it sounds like her estate is broke
it is okay their current home is paid
for but other than that there's nothing
yeah but um
if and when the irs finds this they'll
place liens on that house and it will
have no value
would they kick my grandpa out sure if
he was still absolutely
they'll take they'll take the house
and they might prosecute him
that's my concern you know it's possible
um
is he working at all
no he's retired what is the business
health issues
um they are independent contractors for
a trucking company so they help run
freight you know like line up the trucks
and
um move the orders and that sort of
thing
they do
that they're uh
running distribution they're running
logistics yeah
yeah
okay
so he can't work he's physically
visually
unable to he used to drive truck but he
doesn't obviously anymore yeah um okay
there's a lot of ways to go at this okay
you can go and come out of the cold if
you're out there and you haven't paid
your taxes you don't have to go to jail
you can go see a cpa and file three
years of back returns and come in out of
the cold and they will work with you and
they don't send people to jail that they
do that the ones that go to jail are
people that continue to hide and they
have to chase them down
okay
so do we do that with a 75 year old
though i don't know
okay i don't know realistically
um
you're probably not going to get these
people to do what they should do
but i'll tell you what should happen if
i woke up in their shoes okay the
grandparent's shoes yeah i would sell
the house today and get my money out of
it
and put the money in some you know in a
lock box or something where the irs
can't find it
okay because they're gonna take this
house if they find him
you follow me yeah well her death like i
mean obviously the irs knows when people
die no they don't they don't bother you
with that
okay there's not anything that's there
and she's not got any money uh no you
know and
uh the problem is she owns half this
house and all this credit card debts out
there
so i'm probably going to end up using
this money to try to settle some of that
i guess i don't know
oh god um
yeah
and the other thing is shut the business
down
okay so would it be bad for my mom to
continue yes yes okay yes shut the
business shut the business down
shut the business down and reopen it in
another llc
that your mom owns
she was going to transfer the accounts
to her no no don't transfer anything
okay don't transfer anything let they
let the clients know that she's going to
be operating under a new name and she
opens her own business that is
independent of this disaster
okay and she can continue to run her
business formerly your grandmother's
business without any tax liability and
she needs to pay her freaking taxes
yeah my mom will
okay
when the grandmother passes yeah
does the tax is that not just like it's
the taxes will evaporate yeah but
grandpa but she owns half that house
but but if he and he hasn't paid taxes
has he paid taxes maria or just her
i'm going to guess i'm going to say both
of them
they've been running independent
contractor and put in their pocket for
years
and the problem is and so your grandpa
could go to see a cpa and file three
years of back taxes and try to keep them
off of him
and they'll let him go for the rest of
it
and let her go for the rest of it
because she's not even it's going to be
in her estate and then you got to try to
clean if you get that done you might
keep the house and try to clean up the
credit card debt
in order to keep the house because the
credit cards are going to come after
mom's half of the house house right with
the escape and they should
oh
i'm sorry maria
doesn't sound like this is going to turn
out well but your mom's got the best
course of action which is shut down
today and reopen tomorrow in a new name
and then reset those relationships and
take off that way
oh
wow
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today with the rising cost of
everything a lot of folks are worried
about having enough money
to get through the month the good news
is no matter where you are with money
no matter the state of the economy you
can get on a path to building wealth at
our building wealth live events you
learn a simple common sense principles
to build real wealth in any situation
this building wealth tour is blowing up
we've already sold out two nights and
the rest of these events are on track to
sell out all just any minute so if
you're thinking about joining us don't
wait uh we sold out the phoenix event on
september the 13th and we opened up the
12th and it's getting close to sold out
sacramento november the 1st sold out
minneapolis november 10th just a few
seats in san antonio
just a handful november 15th passes
start as low as 25 you can get a four
pack starting at 60
it's uh most of ramsey personalities
will be there rachel cruz george
campbell me john dolone dr john deloney
and ken coleman we'll all be there i
will be talking and having a panel
discussion it's going to be a blast you
want to come out to this you're going to
learn a lot the people in the other
cities at the sold out events have had a
great job these are three 4 000 person
venues and uh every one of them so far
has been a complete sellout
we will not be opening up other nights
in these other cities even if they sell
out or when they sell out uh because we
don't have venue availability but
phoenix uh we could get a venue so we
had added that extra night at phoenix
and again it's almost gone already so
thank you guys we appreciate you phoenix
you're uh red hot out there for ramsay
stuff we appreciate you
open phones at
825-5225 evans in pittsburgh hi evan
welcome to the ramsey show
hey david rachel how are you great how
can we help
so i have a retirement question
my company's structure has certain
employees falling into the highly
compensated employee category where
we're limited on our 401k yeah because
because the other folks are not
contributing at a high enough rate
exactly yes
so
we're
trying to figure out the best way to get
to that 15 mark what i'm able to
contribute really only gets us two and a
half percent of the 15.
uh my wife uses her company's match that
gets us another
five or six percent total and so we're
stuck on the remaining
you know 10 or so percent if we should
be
over contributing into her 401k for like
tax incentive now or if we should just
go i'm sure it's not over contributing
it's just contributing more than the
match
well yeah more than the match but i
wasn't sure if it made more sense to
have
the money in her company's 401k versus
an individual retirement account because
our total income
bars this from the traditional roth
option as well now you can do back door
roths
okay a back door roth is where you open
and open an after tax
ira and you roll it to a roth
instantaneously i do them every year
understood yeah so with the
with the back door roth should we be
doing that prior to baby step seven
yeah that can be part of the 15 getting
to your 15 yeah what's your household
income
uh it ranges between three and 350 based
on commission
okay so you need forty five thousand
going in you can put nineteen thousand
in your twenty thousand in your wife's
401 yeah and you can you know put all
you're allowed to in how big is the
company you work for
uh it's it's extremely large it's a
staffing firm so the the issue is the
temporary employment
population is what has our total
population
[Music]
contributors yeah okay
none of them participate in the 401k and
so those of you that make money can't
yeah okay yeah i would do i would do all
you can do all she can do and do two
roth iras and if that doesn't get you
there then you can do some mutual funds
that are not not retirement at all but
they're just additional until you get to
15 you need 45 000 going in if you make
300k that's 15
yep but i mean 20 and you're you're two
and a half or three would amount to how
much money
nine thousand so i'm legal i'll get you
to 30. you can get there you can get to
45 then
okay are really close i mean you're
gonna get real close with two roths and
you max out and she maxes out
that gets you to 15. and that's not
going to do with the i mean that's just
baby step four
okay so i guess that the actual question
was did it make sense to be
triggering the extra tax bill for the
door roth versus
just going into a traditional retirement
account you're gonna do them all you
don't have a choice
okay understood yeah and uh it doesn't
trigger taxes
it just makes that that is taxable
income is all it's and uh you always
want to do roth as a post to traditional
uh because most of what is going to be
in your account when you get to
retirement will not be what you have put
in it will be growth and that growth
being tax free under a roth heading is
the best way by far so if you both have
roth options on your 401k you should be
doing that
and regardless of the current tax
situation the long-term implications are
huge compared to the local or in
compared to this year's tax situation so
yeah you do roth the first thing you do
is match the next thing you do is roth
all you can and the next thing you can
do if you run out of roth and can't do
anything else then you would do
traditional in your case
if she has roth available she maxes it
out 401 if you have roth available you
max it out in your 401 and you do two
roth back doors and you're there
sit down with one of our smart investor
pros
that we recommend they can help you plan
right through that it's really not that
difficult to do and they walk you
through you'll get you get people get
your arms around it really really fast
and they can even run the math out and
show you why what i'm talking about is
true
because folks here's the thing if you
get to uh retirement rachel and you got
like
a million dollars in your 401k
okay if it's a roth
it's 100 tax free
if it's not it's 100 taxable
and so you're going to have
250 300 000 in taxes out of that yeah
and so
and the point is is that the growth that
is in your account if you start you know
anytime
before 50 years old the growth that is
in your account what is in your account
is 90 to 95 growth
the rest of it is what you put in so
these little bitty seeds that you plant
grow to big trees yeah and the trees
need to be tax free that's right and
with the roth you're paying with after
tax dollars right you're putting you're
contributing with after tax dollars and
then it is growing
tax free with the traditional you're
putting in pre-tax so it's taxable when
you take it out and all the growth is
taxable yeah and so and what but the
deal is the pre-tax dollars on the roth
are only going to end up but your
contribution portion is only going to be
end up being five or ten percent of what
is in the account later yep and so it's
huge numbers on the growth that are
taxable or not taxable depending on
whether you chose roth besides just
being ignorant or not knowing
why what would cost someone to do a
traditional
well because
what they forget is what what they're
doing is they're they're majoring on
what he was doing there and it's it's a
common thing
is he's saying oh
if i put uh 25 000
or in his case 30 000 in these two
accounts at work
that's i don't have to pay taxes on that
today yeah if it's traditional
it's that that is that goes in without
taxes yeah and so otherwise i have to
pay taxes on it and so what are taxes on
thirty thousand bucks in his situation
ten thousand bucks
you know
and so you're paying taxes out of your
pocket for 10k so here's the odd thing
it's not even an apples to apples okay
so here's the deal if you put in 30 if
he puts in 30 000
and it's all roth
he has to put in another 10 000 out of
his pocket
which and then that allows it to grow
tax-free so in essence he's put in 40
because by paying his taxes now right
right and so it's not if you so you're
comparing a 40 000 investment to a 30
000 investment so it's not even an
apples to apples comparison but if you
said okay i'm going to put in 30
minus the taxes
because it's roth
that would be apples to apples yes and
then when you run it out it ends up
being exactly equal but the way i'm
doing it tricks you into investing more
you see what i'm doing putting more
money in it yeah you're actually putting
more money into the program yeah this
way because you're paying your taxes now
on the roth money yeah and so um
gotcha but you know but sometimes the
little idiots on reddit that criticize
me and all that they they think i can't
do the math because they're comparing
30 against 30 but that's not really the
way real people do it in the real world
right right in the real world i've
actually tricked you into investing an
extra 10 in that case not realizing it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions
whether you're making a few million to
hundreds of millions a year netsuite
gives you the visibility and control of
the things you need to grow like your
financials inventory hr planning
budgeting and more all in one dashboard
go to netsuite.com ramsey right now to
get their free white paper jump start
your cfo career
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today on the debt-free stage right here
and ramsey solutions headquarters in our
lobby michael and melissa are with us
hey guys how are you hi good how are you
dave rachel good to have you guys
welcome where do you all live
up north
north wisconsin or north wisconsin yeah
a little north of eau claire wisconsin
oh yeah yeah wonderful we're glad to
have you guys how much debt have you
paid off six hundred thousand
how long did this take three years and
eleven months
rowdy what was the range of your income
during that time we started at 200 000
and now we're at 350 000. goodness
gracious what do you all do for a living
i am a nurse practitioner a travel nurse
and a faculty and i i'm self-employed i
run a welding fabrication business
same thing as the lady that called
earlier this was newly married she's
doing exactly what she was going to do
faculty and travel nursing can you do it
it's possible it can be done you're
standing there
you can live through it i promise so uh
my goodness i i have no idea what kind
of debt was this 600 000
it was uh unfortunately we were normal
we had 10 credit cards we had student
loans
we had three car payments
we
a loan for the dog pretty much
everything you could get goodness
and then our land and our house
so what happened how did you get
connected up to the ramsey way
well we just got tired of being sick and
tired i think it really happened after i
graduated from grad school with a higher
income but we were still broke so we
just had an i've had it moment i came
home and i told michael we're selling
the truck we're selling the suv we're
selling everything not nailed down i'm
working 100 hours a week this is what
we're going to do wow so how'd you get
connected to us
a friend
said well i heard about this guy on the
radio you should give him a listen so
i listened to one show and then that was
it came in told michael
our life is changing what did you say
michael what did you say um at first i
wasn't i was like oh i don't know
and i think the big thing for me was we
went to the money and marriage down in
iowa
i got to see rachel and i was like i
like this yep yeah
yeah that's awesome oh i'm so glad
that's cool very well done
so
i'm not how much do these trucks and
everything sell for
well we actually well
we broke even on the truck what did it
sell for though like twenty twenty six
five twenty six five yeah so thirty
there what about the other one yep the
suv was 20. okay so that's 50. yeah and
then we had a car which was uh about 25.
you keep it
we kept it and paid it off yep all right
and the suv you sold yeah sold the truck
what else did you sell we sold oh let's
see gosh i don't know he sold everything
that he could in the shop basically i
did a consolidation of the shop
everything that i thought i had to have
yeah i just got rid of and just kind of
down to the simple and we made it work
yeah how much did all that bring oh
probably not as much as i thought but
yeah probably 15 20 000 i suppose okay
and the big sale was we sold their house
this spring
we got you know that three years 11
months we just said we're tired of being
sick and tired we're going to make a
change so we
sold the house that paid off the land
and now we're
renting and cash flowing the development
of the lake house oh
wow
how great okay so how much did the how
much
okay the house is in the 600 then yeah
okay and so how much did it sell for two
well it sold for
450
but that's included in these numbers
no but we we paid off
yeah and then the rest of it went to the
other debts so really you got that much
creditor okay so now i can get because i
couldn't get to 600 in three and a half
years 11 months okay so now i can get
there okay my goodness gracious yeah you
i'm i'm glad that uh michael i'm glad
she didn't sell you
she sold everything you know everything
besides me and the dog yeah the dog made
it yeah
way to go dawg that's good
wow hey you guys that's a pretty intense
did people think y'all were crazy i mean
they still do they still do
and i think especially as a healthcare
professional the culture is to go on
nice vacations have nice cars yeah you
know i was one of the only ones driving
a beater car a dave car if you will so
um just trying to stay strong in that
and not succumb to peer pressure was a
big one yeah yeah but now you don't have
any payments when you make 350 a year
and now you're developing your own lake
house with cash
and um you have a paid for lake house
when this is done and all of that in the
land will be worth how much i'll read
around a million dollars
[Laughter]
you like me now yeah
yeah who's crazy now yeah he's crazy now
who's lost their marbles now
i
traded a pickup truck and an suv in my
house for a paid four million dollar
lake house i like it okay so what was
what was the hardest what was the
hardest part was it selling the stuff
was it working the crazy hours like what
would you say is the thing that was like
yeah that was that was tough
i think for me it was all the crazy
hours especially through the pandemic as
a nurse working in the icu
i've worked straight nights for 11 years
so just many sleepless nights
um
was challenging well and there had to be
some fear that went with all that oh
definitely yeah like i don't know what
i'm getting into down here exactly we
actually made our last consumer debt
payment april of 2020.
right in it right yeah right at the
beginning so
that was great yeah oh man
yeah you look back now you go i can do
anything exactly um yeah and and
at the time like when that car leaves or
that suv goes out of the driveway it's a
big deal but now you know a year later
it's like it was gonna get another car
right it's like 350 000 a year and get
another car when i want one you know and
just pay cash for it right it's not a
big thing so if you drive like no one
else later you can drive like no one
else or you can just have a paid 4
million dollar lake house yeah that too
i like that that works for me too i'll
go with that you guys are awesome i
think the biggest thing for me was the
emotional and mental attachment to
things that everybody around you
gave that item
oh you got to have your pickup because
you deserve it because you got this
business or xyz yeah and for me it was
the disattachment of those material
things to free you up
so you're not a slave to a lender yeah
and you have that ultimate freedom
that's very minimalist of him
yeah but that's a great point though
that you make because i'm like it is the
culture that has set this standard of
living i'm like no you should have x y
and z this is what it should be to be
deeply in debt and when you when you
like yeah detach from just the norm of
the culture you're like okay i'm gonna
just have this complete mindset shift
which is what happened okay what
happened within your marriage because
you guys went to money in marriage which
i'm so glad but what what during this
process i mean was it just incredible
like where you guys are standing in your
marriage today versus five years ago
does it feel different oh huge when we
started the journey we were we had been
married for six years now this um is our
tenure
um you'll probably see a trip to alaska
on there that was our 10-year
anniversary trip um but we're just a
completely different couple than we used
to be we were just kind of co-existing
him doing his thing me doing my thing
you know what did you spend that on what
did you spend this on we just each at
our cards well we had 10 credit cards so
we each had certain cards you know but
now we you know especially those monthly
budget meetings we call them our dream
meetings which is more what they are you
know what what we're dreaming for and
working towards together with a common
goal
and especially the last year when i
started travel nursing we really
came together you know and it's we're
just a completely different couple than
we were absolutely yep i'd say the
biggest thing for us is the
communication
because before you're constantly no
you're married and you're doing back and
forth and you're just never on the same
page
but when you have your budget meetings
month after month and
you're making her accountable for things
and she's making you accountable for
things then anything's possible yeah
because now you take your dollar that
you're putting here and it's working for
you instead of it you're working for it
yeah yes powerful so well said hey we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you you're right on your way to
being one with a lake house i like it
and a copy of the total money makeover
and uh years subscriber year's
membership to financial peace university
way to go guys michael and melissa from
wisconsin 600 000 paid off three years
11 months count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done boys and girls
well done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author
ramsey personality my daughter
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five in canada is shaylee hi k hey
shaylee how are you
oh hi thank you so much
thanks so much for having us on and i
have my husband john here with me
so we are wondering
um we currently have stock investments
and we're wondering if we should pull
them out
and put them towards our mortgage to
more aggressively pay down our mortgage
are you debt-free except the house
yes we are okay how much do you owe on
the home
uh 760 thousand and how much do you have
in stock
uh 215 so right now yeah
you have retirement investments aside
from this
uh we have 170 000 in rsps okay
and what's your household income
so currently i'm on maternity leave as
of january this year i was making about
250 to 300 dollars i was i am a
pediatrician um i'm a mature belief i
don't know when i'm gonna go back or
what it's gonna look like in the future
uh my husband makes about 200 grand a
year so right now that's our income it's
about 200 grand how old are
43 turning 44 on monday
cool all right
well um so here's the thing if you don't
use the stock to pay it off
it's the same thing as saying i owe 500
000 on my house
and i went down and i got a new mortgage
for 700
to put 200 into stock
okay so if you had 500 000 on your house
would you go get a new mortgage for 700
to put 200 into stock
um would i do that i'm not i'm not sure
i don't think i would do that it's not a
trick question
it's just a matter of you know
because usually when you reverse it like
that it activates some people go oh i
wouldn't do that
usually i mean it's not it's not 100 but
i mean
that's the thing so
here's the deal
when we studied 10 167 millionaires and
asked them in detail how they became
millionaires what the process that they
used was
a very very very small percentage less
than 10 percent
uh
you used investing instead of paying off
their house
uh instead they usually filled up their
retirement accounts and paid off their
house
and they didn't have they didn't have a
side stock thing going like this until
they paid off their house it's very
unusual
statistically
to become a millionaire when you're
doing it this way
um and because in effect you have
borrowed on your home
to have these investments in effect you
didn't
you didn't technically tactically do
that but but in effect that's the net
effect of where you are today does that
make sense
yes and just to give you a little bit
more information so we that we put the
money in um
before getting the home it's a bit
backwards but um and the money that we
put in a few years ago um went up to
like 250 something and then it's come
down with the um the economic situation
in our world it's come down so we've
lost maybe like unrealized losses of 40
grand so our investor is like don't take
the money out now it's going to be
realized losses
like because of also your steps like
actually we've gone we've done it
backwards so we're
should we just pull it out even though
where you are today from where you are
today the shortest distance based on the
data that we have
to wealth is not riding the market it's
becoming getting the house paid off
that's the shortest distance based on
the data that we have so
if i woke up in your shoes that i would
use all of that to decide i'm going to
throw this out it doesn't pay off the
house but the good news is you've got a
two to a four hundred thousand dollar
income depending on your decision
to be able to knock out the other 500
fairly quickly
and you're young right and with no house
payment and that great income
the amount of money you can pile up in
retirement accounts and or other
investments later
yeah
but um
you know investment advisors have never
been known for telling you to become
debt free
because it takes it takes the money out
from their management they don't make a
commission
they don't make a commission on you
anymore
right
and then we would use the chunk because
we'd have to pay taxes on that money in
investments um so we would just take a
chunk of that to save for the taxes
exactly and put the rest on the house
exactly it's not necessarily tax
efficient move i would agree with your
investment advisor on that it's not
about tax efficiency it's about okay 10
years from today where do i really want
to be
playing the stock market or do i want to
have this house paid off and then with
the cash flow i've got be playing the
stock market that's where i would want
to be and as a matter of fact it's where
i've been for decades
i haven't had a house payment in so long
i don't even remember what it's like
long time
well there's just the freedom to it too
so yeah we're the
an investment professional may look at
it and be like well it's not tax
efficient you're going to be taking
losses you're going you know all of the
the math side which is all true um
there is something to be said though
about man that getting that um fast
forwarded so fast to pay off the house
and have that freedom is huge
adam is in detroit hey adam welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave hi rachel hey what's up
uh thank you so much dave for the total
money makeover changed my life i've had
my i've had it moment and thank you
rachel for helping get my wife on board
with your youtube content she absolutely
loves it thank you oh
uh we've had many wins in our baby step
two recently selling anything that's not
bolted to the floor i just sold my dream
car yesterday and paid off 17k of credit
cards this morning
wow
yep no more stupid bachelor money
decisions so we can start our family
so we're we're very gazelle intense i've
got a second job on the weekends pays
pretty good but we're having
a struggle staying intense and then also
finding time for each other
i'm just looking for a recommendation on
how to balance that and find the time
and still stay gazelle intense because
we still have quite a bit of debt yeah
so how many how many hours you guys
working
she's working 60 plus with like
depending on traffic right now four
hours of commuting every day good lord
and uh
i'm probably working 80 hours between
the two jobs give or take oh wow yeah
y'all what is your commute
uh i work from home mostly during the
day unless i'm teaching classes in the
afternoon at the studio but it's 20
minutes
ma'am i would move closer to her work
yes we've been having this discussion
for a while
she's not sure if she's going to stay in
the career if she does she doesn't
if she leaves she doesn't want to do
that career anymore so it's she's just
kind of undecided on on her career path
i'm going to decide pretty quick because
i'm not spending four hours a day on the
road
absolutely something nice
that's where your time is going it's not
because you're gonna intense it's
because she lives in a car
yes
i mean she's working five days a week or
six
five days a week
yeah
okay so that's
what 24 hours 20 hours a week she's been
in the car
i think everything's under construction
right now and it's terrible what do you
um
what do you guys make of you make what
are y'all what we all make this year
household incomes just over a hundred
thousand okay what does she make
she's making
us
38.
bull crap
okay i'm changing jobs tomorrow
what does she do
she's a pharmacy technician okay
well i mean she needs to move
take a job closer to you guys or she you
guys need to move up there
i'm not commuting forty
four four hours for a thirty eight
thousand dollar job
that's what's wrong
yeah i i agree a hundred percent um i've
conveyed that
you know she she loves the work
but not the commute so so is there not
somewhere near you that needs a pharmacy
technician
yes uh she does compound pharmacy it's a
little bit different yeah i mean can we
not get closer than two hours away
the answer to that question is yes is
she being stubborn possibly
yeah you're sweet
you know that's your issue it's not
whether you're gazelle intense i mean
you're you know you've got you've got
some career things and and uh commute
things that are screwed up here uh i'd
make changes on that i mean the number
of times i'm gonna commute four hours is
close to never
it's right there next to never yeah and
to adam look to see how long you guys
are going to be in this minus the
commute but just this in general and to
say okay how how can we sustain this
going forward and what that looks like
so having those conversations of
priorities can be really important but
thanks for the call most people i can
tell them to turn off the tv and they
find that many hours a week and her i
got to get her out of the car
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host we help people
build wealth do work that they actually
love and create real
amazing relationships rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life
open phones at aaa 825-5225
markel is with us in sacramento hey
markell how are you
hi dave hi rachel how are you guys great
how can we help
i had a question for you this uh this
afternoon i am a christian and i'm a
worship pastor at a church
and um i'm feeling for that i've heard
you in the past talk about while you're
in baby step two and three that while
you do pay your tithe because that comes
off the top
that perhaps extra generosity above that
is not always recommended my church can
sometimes
require of us staff to participate in
things like backpack drives or
shoe boxes at christmas
above and beyond because they don't want
us asking our people to do something
that we wouldn't do and i think that's a
good idea in general
but most specifically i want to know how
you reconciled the story of the widow's
might where it seemed as though
jesus commended her for giving all that
she had like it doesn't seem like she
was in a position of strength
as she gave um i just want to know how
you thought through that story
well there's several things i i'll send
you a copy of the book the legacy
journey where we address uh several of
these things in detail it's the only
christian uh
book i've done um and i'll send you a
copy of it i think you'll find it
interesting uh thank you the widow's
might is the only time in scripture
that we could make the argument that the
offering comes not tithe but an offering
which is above the tithe
we distinguish as christians which which
is what you're doing a difference
between offerings and tithes
okay tithe is off the top before you do
anything else first fruits from proverbs
and um now you and i are having a
doctrinal discussion not a legalistic
discussion okay yes sir for those of you
listening in to markella
okay but the uh uh so ty ty this before
i do anything as an evangelical
christian and then offerings are
everywhere in scripture are from surplus
and you can make the argument easily
logically that and while you're in debt
you don't have surplus
while you don't have an emergency fund
you don't have a surplus now that's
where i you know and past baby step
three is when i started doing
other kinds of giving in addition to my
tithe okay once i got there because i
need to take care of my own family first
or i'm worse than an unbeliever
now there's lots of interpretations and
fun reading on the widow's mite but if
you want to reach down um
there's a real thing there where he's or
jesus is condemning the pharisees for
having a widow do anything
in giving
and so if you
reach down late in that passage you'll
see him
woe to you scribes and pharisees he
starts he starts going after them
as
as
having forced this widow to do this
and it comes more off of maybe the
teaching and there's argument about this
among theologians which is a valid
discussion or valid argument okay but
generally in north american evangelicals
have used the widow's might to raise
money for a building
right and they stand in the pulpit and
go well people give they give
sacrificially look at what jesus
commended the widow
and uh they give sacrificially like that
and i think if you dig into that you're
gonna find that might not have been the
actual tone it might have been him
condemning them for forcing this widow
because a widow and an orphan in the old
testament should be taken care of not
milked
correct
correct
you know
you would know that
basically i can tell already in our
discussion you would know that we have a
mandate as believers to take care of
widows and orphans
right and so that's anytime i'm teaching
generosity i you know i'll say hey 58 of
single moms let blow the poverty's live
poverty level now they're not
technically widows but man there's a
real case to be made for that i'll go
even a step further uh if a guy is
deployed overseas and his wife is here
and he's serving in the military
we ought to be taking care of her
you know not just the gut not just the
government we in the church ought to be
taking care of her and her family and
making sure they're okay you know i mean
we just have a mandate to love each
other well with money
uh in these situations and so it appears
that since the widow's here's the
problem scripture is always consistent
agreed
yes god does not come pro cross purposes
with himself and i you can't find and
i've studied it for 30 years i can't
find anywhere else in scripture
that an offering is done
out of sacrifice it's always done out of
surplus except the widow's might which
makes it suspect the way we're
interpreting it
i agree i agree would you as one more
maybe think that the story of elisha
where
he went to the widow in the sun and that
she was going to make the bread and die
he said no give it to me first
any thoughts on that particular passage
yeah i
you know again that that's a uh
that's a valid point uh and of course we
know that he then uh brought her son
back to life
or someone died yes and the prophet laid
hands on him and he came back to life so
there's something there's something in
that message that's in there too and the
whole jezebel and the prophets of baal
and the whole that whole story right in
there of his uh
of elisha
elijah in one minute he's king of the
world the next minute he's in full
depression mode
and um so there's uh uh
you know and how that comes into this
how how that comes into play on that
lack um now that that was that was
someone that was a person taking care of
another person
that was not a donation of the backpack
fund
you got it and so that that would not be
an offering that would just be one of us
loving each other well and so you know i
got i got i got two dollars and i share
one of my dollars with somebody who's
hurting
um you know we're both broke but um hey
we're gonna we're gonna do this together
that's just a love and kindness and
compassion those kinds of things that's
not an
offering is when i'm giving to a
a cause to an organization to um you
know and i'm all about backpacks and
christmas boxes we do all of them uh so
i'm not not against any of that and
again
i i am firmly convinced god's not going
to be mad about any of this when we get
to heaven
yes correct i'm firmly convinced he
smiles at all generosity
uh
i i but i am also i'm convinced that
sometimes people get manipulated on this
subject a lot
and pushed around so um i i'm not mad at
your church for suggesting you guys do
this i understand why they're doing it i
think it's a i think i get it i
i i it would seem hypocritical to ask
all the people to do it and you guys not
be doing that makes sense yeah and if
it's a certain and if it's a small
dollar amount markel i mean who's to say
yeah put it in the budget and and do it
i mean again it's not a legalistic thing
but if you make 50 000 a year and you
give 10 000 to the building fund as an
offering
and you got you got ten thousand dollars
in credit card debt that's just that
just that doesn't sit in my spirit right
it just doesn't feel like truth yeah and
uh not the truth is a feeling i don't
believe that but that's a great
discussion hang on i'll send you a copy
of legacy journey any of you that want
to read more on that stuff did a whole
uh
whole treatment on some of these
different arguments on the widows mind
in there because it's a fun discussion
as long as everybody doesn't get torqued
out about it and mad
and so try try to avoid that raquel's
posture was wonderful yeah absolutely
markel thank you thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my off my
daughter is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five
two two five
have you had enough
enough of waking up at 2 30 worried
about how you're going to fill up your
tank
enough of wondering how you're going to
put supper on the table enough of
wondering how the key lights are going
to stay on enough of worrying about
retirement
enough of putting up with sally mae
won't leave the house she stays in the
spare bedroom
hey your hope will come back when you
decide to control the controllables
we want to come alongside you we want to
make it easier than ever to get the
expert help you need to solve this money
thing
so for a limited time we've marked down
our best-selling life-changing products
up to 83 percent you can get your hands
on our number one best-selling books and
tools like the total money makeover and
so much more at prices that'll work for
you
yeah while everything else is going up
we're going to give you a deal
it's just what you need to finally take
control of your money our team isn't
stopping there you can get a free
financial coaching call with any
purchase talk with a ramsey preferred
coach about your specific money
questions and plans
they'll help you make the goals and you
can go from i've had it
to i've got this
enough with the worrying
enough with the fighting enough with the
losing sleep take control of your money
and your life for a limited time get up
to 83 off and a free financial coaching
call
when you shop with us at
ramseysolutions.com slash enough
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
enough caitlin is with us in salt lake
city hi caitlin how are you
i'm joe well how about you guys better
than we deserve what's up
awesome well my husband and i are
basically house broke
and i'm
stressing out and i don't really know
what to do
okay
how much is your house payment
it's about fourteen hundred fifty
dollars every month
my husband works full-time
uh earning about 54k every year
i'm full i'm home excuse me home
full-time with our two boys and we're
going to be starting homeschooling in
the fall
how much debt have you got other than
the house
actually we're debt-free as soon as the
those government checks came in we paid
off the loss of our debt i quit my job
in may 2020
and i've been home ever since
okay
um
well something has to change doesn't it
his income
or that house
because you bought that house based on
you working
we we bought it the uh excuse me back in
2016. based on you both based on both of
you working
right when your income stopped for you
to come home
that made you not be able to afford the
house
right
so either we could develop some kind of
a game plan to get his income up
substantially and quickly
or we need to move down in house
okay because his take-home pay is what
four grand uh
around there i think yeah i can't uh
you're approaching 50 of his take-home
pay is your house payment that's not
sustainable
right
it's stressing out
well you don't have any room what what's
his i can tell the distress in your
voice caitlyn um what's his feeling with
everything does he feel the same sense
of urgency and stress
and weight that you're feeling
yes like he he does not like it um but
we
don't know
i mean we want god to be in everything
that we're doing we just don't know what
that looks like specifically
i can help you with that the blessings
of the lord
have no sorrow added to them
so we can safely say this house is not a
blessing
it it has been for some time god passed
away into it has sorrow
by definition
biblically
when you have sorrow added to something
it is not a blessing from god
that's true
by definition now it would it could have
been a blessing earlier
when you had both incomes coming in and
it was a reasonable house payment as a
percentage of your take-home pay
but the past is the past you all have
made other decisions now and so you you
know there's three possible options
because the math is not going to change
until you change it
you're going to go back to work he or
he's going to increase his income
dramatically doing something different
or you're going to sell the house
what's he do for a living
she's a team leader at a financial
company
a team leader at a financial company
makes fifty grand
yeah but he's a manager of
the
agents and teams and stuff
of the what
he's a team leader of
about 15 people
agents that take calls for the financial
company
okay
all right how long have you been doing
that
uh
10
years all right well there has been a
dramatic shift in employment in the
marketplace in the past two years
and what people and what people are
making
okay
now not everyone has experienced wage
increase because the overall wages have
only increased about five and a half
percent but we've seen entire sectors
of of the
of the workplace their incomes double
for instance developers and programmers
okay software engineers
they're they've gone a lot of them have
gone from 100k to 200k
depending on the category that they're
in and what their skill level is as an
example okay and there's other stuff out
there plenty i mean entry-level stuff
has gone from ten dollars to twenty
dollars and in some cases to thirty
dollars an hour
and and it sounds like your husband has
is a and a dead end thing here and he
may need to rethink what he's doing
this might be his wake-up call on his
career path
and so i mean if he could be on on a
career path that says hey when when i
take this job and then i do this thing i
get this raise and i do that thing i get
that raised
and you can see your way through this in
a year or two or three then you can hold
your breath and get out of it but you
can't hold your breath forever
eventually you're gonna drown
right
so
i i you know
you guys like the house i can tell by
the way you're defending it
it's not so much i liked it it just gave
my my mom a place to stay after my dad
passed away they didn't have their
financial things together so they didn't
have any retirement
and so that's why
i feel like that was kind of a god
moment that now i feel like it's not
yeah
i think it's okay it was then and it's
not now is she still with you caitlyn is
she still living with you guys yes
okay so moving also means
um moving her moving her or finding a
place for like i mean it's that it's
more than a discussion than just your
nuclear family
right yeah there's a lot going on here
kiddo so what i would if i were in your
shoes what would i do okay i would set
myself a deadline that says i have a new
career path
that i can see light at the end of the
tunnel for if i'm your husband
that allows us to afford this house
by the end of the year
i'm going to give myself four to six
months
and if i don't have that new career path
by spring in underway i'm going to sell
the house because i'm not going to sit
here in denial and act like this is okay
because it's not okay it's killing y'all
now you can survive it for a short
period of time
a year maybe whatever like that well she
quit her job in 2020 so it's been two
years they're not surviving they're
there no no but i'm just saying she's
been feeling it for a while yeah yeah so
i'm gonna send you ken coleman's book uh
from paycheck to purpose
and i want your husband to jump on the
website i tell you what i'm also gonna
send him the assessment and let him take
the assessment on to send him in a
direction
of some ways and things he could go do
things he can look at but i want him to
uh
change horses
i don't think he's being paid very well
and 50k is okay for some things but i
think he can do better and if he can do
better you can keep this house but if he
can't
or won't
then you can't keep the house because
you're not going to be able to keep it
long-term something's going to blow up
here
hang on this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage garrett and judy
are with us hey guys how are you good hi
good welcome where do you all live
joplin missouri oh fun good welcome to
nashville thank you how much debt did
you pay off
131 dollars no no just kidding 131
182
close enough
how long did it take about five and a
half years five and a half years right
and your range of income during that
time we started at about a little under
40 000 went up to about 90 and we're
back down to around 80. okay cool what
do y'all do for a living i'm a manual
machinist
and i'm a children's minister oh very
good good good good what kind of debt
was the 131 it's all the normal stuff it
was uh cars and student loans vehicles
well i said cars credit cards medical
bills a business loan
you were like normal all of it yes so
what happened five and a half years ago
plugged into the ramsey way
well uh when we got married my parents
paid for us to go through uh financial
peace and i love your parents they yeah
me too
they're wonderful and at the time i was
23 and thought i
am broke and smarter than dave and what
he's doing is not what we're going to do
um
and then did you go through and still
thought that uh no well you kind of uh
he was 23. we were ish for a while
i kind of thought i mean maybe you just
didn't go to class at all because of
that no no that would have been me i
would have just dissed the class yeah
okay we we went but um
so the first so we kind of started to
get serious um
and and we started to realize the
financial chains that we were in and
once you start to realize the chains
that you're wearing
and they come off you start to realize
some other stuff and
the first
four years
i realized i was drowning in alcoholism
and um
so once i surrendered that to the lord
and got some help
uh we paid off seventy thousand dollars
in the last two years yeah once we kind
of got that out of the way got on the
same page
uh got some counseling got our marriage
working um we really were able to buckle
down and make some real progress so
you've been dry three and a half years
uh two and a half years two and a half
mm-hmm way to go he wrote
congratulations that's awesome that's
even a bigger deal oh that's a more
bigger deal
that's incredible we now are both uh
ministry leaders for a celebrate
recovery ministry at our church yay
that's a wonderful ministry yeah that's
a wonderful thing it is particularly
when it's led by someone like you guys
wow
wow
how proud of him are you judy oh beyond
proud it's it's changed the course of
our family oh for sure you know our boys
will never see him drinking and won't
know
that person they get to see
daddy how old are your boys uh three and
four oh so they'll never know that no
yeah praise god yeah we're very grateful
that is so awesome yes
very cool incredible very cool yeah
getting out that's easy once you're
doing it sober that's right yeah that's
right he's able to make some stumbling
through is not gonna work yeah when your
life is out of control your money's out
of control yeah yeah so where in the
journey did those kind of cross for you
guys because you said you were we were
starting this four and a half years ago
yeah so
the big thing was probably our van
we
we bought um we needed to upgrade
because we were having our second child
and um we we paid too much for it
um and it was a point of um contention
for us for a long time
um and so finally we decided you know
what we're gonna just pay it off and be
done with it um and and that was kind of
what led us into um really going hard
and and that gazelle intensity
um instead of just kind of well we're
we're sticking with our budget but we're
not really but that was after the sober
date
that was actually just before just
before what happened that woke you up on
on the sobriety
oh man i'm gonna cry
me too so it's okay we'll do it together
i found myself
with my two-year-old's piggy bank and a
wire hanger
fishing out money to drink that night
and the lord said
you're behaving like an addict
and you probably have a problem
and so
after that i sought out like i said a
celebrate recovery ministry in our area
and went and admitted to them and then
later that night to her and um
the lord took that from me amen yeah it
was awesome
yeah it's a powerful thing
yeah and there's stuff like that those
moments when you you got that visual
of that piggy bank in your hand and you
you if you have something that strong as
a milestone
that changes everything that's a that's
a powerful picture yeah so before that
my life was just totally all about me
um and then after that i realized that
the way that i was living not only with
the alcohol but with the money was a
threat to my kids and uh
nobody threatens my kids
you know and so
that inspired me to sell my trucks and
sell my guns
and
selling everything hustle grind i threw
shingles for two and a half years wow um
which was not fun no but uh and i'm glad
i don't do that anymore but uh
just as my kids will never have to see
me under the influence they'll never
know
uh a family that carries any debt yeah
so you're a good man thank you
that's powerful i mean it's it's
unbelievable like the redemption part
usually what we get on this stage you
know obviously comes for the debt free
right that's what you're you're here for
but always always underneath that are
other stories and life going on it's
life going on and
the money problems end up being it's
usually a symptom right of other things
of out of control or controlling right
like all of that and that's the beauty
of being debt-free not only the
financial side where you guys have no
payments right you're completely free
mathematically financially which is just
incredible
but there is a spiritual emotional
freedom in other areas of your life that
i think it really does it affects and
you guys are just living proof of
complete redemption in in even bigger
ways absolutely
so incredible job you guys thank you
honored to know you i'm proud of you
thank you way to go heroes both boys i'm
excited your family tree i mean the
change is
like you said too the legacy is
incredible absolutely incredible
well very cool very very cool
uh
yeah it's a family tree change yeah
that's how it's done right there
and uh so how's it feel to be free on
the debt-free side
no doubt it feels wonderful it really
does um
you know we decided to come out here and
make it a trip whereas before it would
have been really difficult
to do any sort of thing like this really
pension pennies but now i mean we get to
rent the car that we want we get to stay
where we want we get to have very
expensive meals
that we never
do yeah it's it's been really wonderful
so um just to be able to do those things
um
and and now finally really just our life
is not careening downhill at 95 miles an
hour any more financially and otherwise
and uh
we can breathe yeah
very cool
very cool
what are the boys names
judah is our oldest and he's four and
then josiah is our youngest okay and
they're at home with a babysitter yeah
because mom and dad are in nashville
yeah it's going to nice dinner not
cutting anyone's food at the table
it was our uh our eighth anniversary
this week too so we said let's just make
it oh there we go that's good well happy
anniversary happy anniversary yeah we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure this is very cool and uh
you guys got a great story and a great
great change god has touched your lives
in a very powerful way and a copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody and help them get
started in a financial peace university
membership for a year
make sure you let someone go through
that or you guys go through that you'll
probably run into somebody in the
celebrate recovery that needs a little
help with that
there's a hand and glove thing with
addicts and money problems yeah it tends
to be that way yep that's the way that
rolls so very good you guys very good
very well done we're proud of you heroes
man
all right it's garrett and judy joplin
missouri 131 000 paid off in five and a
half years making 40 to 90 to 80. count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today joshua 1 9 this is
my command be strong and courageous do
not be afraid or discouraged for the
lord your god is with you wherever you
go
winston churchill said success is not
final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue
that counts
thank you for joining us america i was
hosting with delony i guess probably a
week or two ago and i didn't say the
scripture and the quote of the day to
lead in we just came in from commercial
work and i was like
and thou has been
profited about i like oh like i started
she started battling and he was like i
was reading the scripture but it was
like this you know
holy wonderful and he was like are you
having a stroke what is happening i was
like it's the scripture he's like oh my
gosh came back from commercials like
thou and heaven
he's like what are you saying
so
we will always prep you america
you never know scripture
we gotta let you gotta let you know
what's happening
so you don't think we've had a stroke
george is with us in jefferson city
missouri hey george how are you
hey dave hey rachel uh it's an honor to
be on here and talk to you um i'm great
how are you great better than we deserve
how can we help
good um a little background information
my wife and i um are both in the
agriculture field and
our dream as well as
uh many other people our age is to own a
farm and
this day and age it's got its challenges
with land being as high as it is and
um we have a a very close family friend
that has
made us an offer to um
let us have her farm
when she is gone and she's just turning
70
she's a widow
and she likes to
travel and take her horse trailer and
she lives in her horse trailer
occasionally
for weeks at a time and
she kind of wants us to come and and
take take care of
the remaining animals at her farm and
then kind of care for her place and
eventually give it to us when she's gone
we are just overwhelmed with the
opportunity
we had several questions and i want to
get your opinion on a few things
we currently have a house that
i guess we would potentially sell
if we decide to go through with this and
she had offered for us to just move into
her home and she would build a small
shop or shouse on her property
she has a
rental house across the road from her
that she
said she'd gladly kick the tenant out
and she could live there or we could
live there
the other option is for us to build a
home on her farm
um
my wife and i have definitely decided
that we do not want to move into her
home because when she comes back from
trips
um that's her house and and this
graciousness of an offer that is um i
think you know she
she needs to stay there when she's when
she's home
um that being said
how old are you guys
i am 30 and my wife is 28. are you
planning on farming this full time when
this all matters i i'm i yes um but we
both have we both have uh steady jobs
but how many acres is this
uh this is 80 and uh dave my wife and i
also uh we we rent a farm right now and
we raise sheep and um that generates a
fair amount of money um
on top of our on top of our uh
our will you be working her farm under
this arrangement
uh our own animals though she she she
she actually has uh mules and that's
what she takes and and and rides all
across the country um and she's i'm
saying are you going to be are you going
to be a farmer on this farm
oh yes sir yes sir that's what i'm
asking all right yes sir okay and so
here here's what here's what this is
this lady
is unbelievably kind and generous and
she holds everything with a very open
hand
yes sir okay
uh does she she obviously doesn't have
heirs
she actually does have uh two sons and
that was our first uh concern you know
why is this not going to them well
she is she has made it very clear that
her kids are taken care of with her
they i guess they have a fair amount of
money and one of both the kids are
taking care of her grandkids will be
taken care of with
uh her retirement her
i think she has quite a bit of money and
other um
so okay
this uh if i'm in your shoes i i i
number one you're unbelievably grateful
and you should be
yeah but without anything structured
around this this is very dangerous for
your family
sure you could you could spend 15 years
here and end up with nothing if she
changed her mind in the middle of it
right and so that's just not okay
sure so um
uh you know we can either sit back and
wait on her to pass away and you just go
have your career
and you don't worry about this farm
until then
um that's option one and that's a that's
a clean option that's fine and then if
she does leave it to you then we'll deal
with it then but if she wants you to
live there now and start working the
farm
on the auspices that it's going to be
yours then there needs to be something
structured
in terms of the ownership of this the
cleanest way to do that would be for her
to go ahead and deed it to you with her
having a life estate
which means that she would have a she
could live there as long as she's alive
sure
and now um that's
that's a clean way to do it but it's a
pretty extreme thing to ask of someone
that's this loosey-goosey and this
generous
now uh she doesn't it would be me
putting my own livestock on the farm
i don't know if that's if i made that
you're structuring your whole life
around a farm that is not yours
so should we get some
now she wanted to update her will and
put a tod on the farm and um that would
help
is there something uh she can change
that though as long as she's alive
right now the way we kind of looked at
it well if she pulls the plug in 15
years we've had
we've lived there taking care of it
we've enjoyed it for 15 years and we've
been able to sit there and save money
for the past 15 years and we can go but
you don't own anything for 15 years and
everything around you has gone up for 15
years okay
no
no
so
the right way to go about it is to get
some uh legal
yeah documentation and and
i think the two of you need to sit down
with her and with an attorney
and i i
i the pro the downside is it's awkward
even for me just sitting here saying it
to ask this lady to go ahead and deed
the property to you but uh but that's
the only way i know that you're going to
be protected
okay okay and i worry about this thing
unraveling because
i mean suddenly one of these kids raises
up and talks mama back into it and man
those are the calls we get every day
here on the air stuff that went stuff
that's weird and went sideways
right well i was hoping you could shed
some light on some questions that i need
to ask in order to that i haven't
thought about you know and um i think
you're right i think there's a lot of
questions here and uh the thing you want
to do on stuff like this is you want to
figure out
okay um how is she protected and how are
you protected if everything goes
sideways
okay if nobody you know and if you can
figure out your exit strategies like you
said you'd kind of thought about that
you know we could just leave after 15
years and we would have had a free place
to stay during that time that's not
totally bad
but the bad part of it then is is you've
not owned a farm all of that time
right
yeah you're sitting around waiting on
this one that didn't come
right okay
all right it's just a hard relational
thing because she sounds like such a
sweet lady and and i don't want to put
her in jeopardy in this either and i
don't want her kids raising up thinking
you guys have come in there and taken
advantage of her in some way or another
yeah um you know lots of clear
communication over communicate with
everybody as i say with the sun i mean
everything is just like hey we're gonna
get it all out there yeah she needs to
communicate with the kids in front of
you
um or written an email
and then have a good estate planning
attorney structure this in a trust or a
deed over now
um but something that that uh
i i just i don't want her getting
remarried and changing her mind
right you know i mean that that's a lot
she's 70. and she could and that into
your point protecting her she you know
she still has you know
another yeah
10 15 20 years another way to do it
would just be get on with your life and
go by there and feed the animals
yeah and not worry about all this yeah
just keep your house and go by there and
feed the animals and if it all works out
it works out yeah that's that's a like
that's the easiest one
uh other than the fact you got to drive
over there to beat the animals but hey i
yeah
wow
i put this hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you